ce vendredi au campus d'acheter à jouy
en josas entreprises et collectivités
ont participé aux smart days ce rendez
vous désormais annuel organisé par la
cci versailles yvelines aborde chaque
année une évolution technologique
les objets connectés en 2014 l'économie
circulaire pour cette année gérard
bacheliers qui était l'initiative de cet
événement nous en donne une définition
ce qui est important c'est tout
simplement que l'on puisse réutiliser
les déchets des entreprises pour en
faire de nouveaux produits ce couac
c'est la save la plus simple définition
d'économie circulaire c'est à dire qu'on
évite d'utiliser les ressources
de là les ressources qui diminue de plus
en plus et l'énergie qui de plus en plus
pour justement pouvoir utiliser les
déchets et les ré exploiter dans de
nouveaux produits
tables rondes et ateliers ont permis aux
acteurs de la région de mieux
appréhender ce nouveau concept
d'économie aux nombreux enjeux
je pense que c'est d'ouvrir
sur la nouvelle économie sur l'économie
du nouveau monde c'est à dire une
économie qui est une économie de
fonctionnalité une économie circulaire
une économie de partager une économie
qui marie les grandes les deux grandes
transformations de ce siècle
c'est dire les questions digital et
environnemental si la transition
technologique a pu détruire des emplois
l'économie circulaire ancrée et 3700
entreprises travaillent dans ce secteur
ce qui représente plus de 600 mille
emplois en france